[Music]
here are the nominees for achievement
and costume design it was a big night I
was nervous
I was excited and
I was scared I was very nervous about
seeing the skit because I felt like we
were dressed alike she had a cape I had
a cape I tried to laugh and have levity
with that skit but I was like this is
the category that's going to be read my
fate is in her hands and she's making a
joke and the Oscar goes to
okay
Black Panther
[Applause]
I had an overwhelming sense of
empowerment after the after they called
my name all of a sudden I had so much
confidence and the actor who was a part
of the skin he bowed and gave me my
Oscar with his head lowered so I thought
I'm going to soak up that moment too and
I'm gonna hold for a second and then go
I know all of this is timed you're not
supposed to hold you're not supposed to
laugh and giggle in between but I
couldn't help it
hahaha
[Applause]
being in front of the whole crowd I felt
like family it honestly did I saw you
know the cast of Black Panther I saw
Ryan coogler I saw the producers so I
stood before my film family and it felt
really really good Marvel may have
created the first black superhero but
through costume design we turned him
into an African king
thank you
foreign